[Music]
thankfully someone
did uh have their
camera phone out was able to capture
this otherwise
we may have never seen what actually
happened
hear that woman on that video yelling
and whoever that is i think she could
have saved his life
[Music]
how are you feeling
there were multiple abrasions to his
face scratches
i believe it was his right side ear
swollen purple
the officers none of them are rookies
they've been in law enforcement for some
time the conduct that appears on the
video that is circulating is not
indicative
of the croft county sheriff's department
or any law enforcement
agency in this in this area
that is
reprehensible conduct
in which
a suspect
is beat in that fashion that response
was was not consistent with the training
that they receive as certified officers
with the arkansas law enforcement
training academy
that will be investigated by the state
police
[Music]